Ne yapıyorsun fotoğrafa bakıp Aldanmayın
Meksikalı değiliz Ben Kayserili bir
ailenin bir kızayım bizim ailemizi 5
generasyon dan beri hiç erkek çocuk
uğramamış Kayseri bir aile için
teknolojik bir konu dik Ben de geleneğe
uygun olarak üç tane harika kız evlat
sahibi oldu oldu bizim ailede o kadar
çok trajedi vardı ki bugünkü gibi kaç
tane tedex konusu çıkar acaba diye
düşündüm Çok komik garip Absürt kadınlar
vardı ailede başlarda inanılmaz şeyler
gelirdi çocuktan farketmedi bunların çok
kötü olduklarını İlerleyen zamanlarda
acaba bu kadınlar
ben sana gelen bu garip şeylerle nasıl
baş ettiler ve ayakta kaldılar diye çok
düşündüm de hiç birinden bizlerin
etkilenmesine izin vermediler sonra
anladım ki bunu sonradan düşer jetonları
diyorum bugün inşallah kitap yapacağım
sonra anladım ki birbirlerinin etrafında
o kadar güzel çevirmişler de ki bir
düşse Ömür kaldırıyordu birinin aşırı
sönmeye kalksa diğer Ona yetişiyordu
böylece hayatta kalmayı başardılar
Bunlar da benim kızlarım Selin Lara ve
Arya anneciğim canım anneciğim Allah
rahmet eylesin Bizim ailede teyzemle
birlikte ailenin ilk üniversite mezunu
olan kız çocuklarıydı kendi Anneleri
okuma yazma bilmiyordu Annem diş
doktoruydu uçuş vizyoner etrafına ışık
saçan harika bir kadındı cerrahi
asistanı yapıyordu
a
Ben babama ile etrafımız çok da güzel
bir kadın olunca onun aslında evde
otursa çocuklarına baksa daha iyi olacak
konusunda kendisini ikna edip evde
kalmasını karar vermişler Annem bizi
büyüttüğümüz Türkan de inanılmaz işler
yaptı bu kadar Annem de şunu gördüm
büyürken hayalleri olan hayallerine
ulaşma becerisi olan yetenekleri
barındıran ışığı olan kadınları
Hayallerinin peşinden koşmasını
engellerseniz onların ışığının yavaş
yavaş söndüğünü görüyorsunuz Ben Aslı
ben büyürken kendi ışığını toplarken
fark etmeden annemin ışığın söndüğünü
görmüş antenli bir karar verdim Hayatta
kimsenin kendi sevdiklerim insanlar da
dahil olmak üzere Eşi çocuğu kimse için
Hayallerinden vazgeçme cektim istediğimi
bu İstediklerinin peşinden gidecek karar
vermesi kolayda yaşamaz o kadar kolay
olmuyor Hayır bükücülük buradan geliyor
galiba Neyse böyle olunca tabi İsyan
İsyankar çocuk oluyorsunuz ailenize ilk
çocuğuyum bu hayatımı bayağı zorlaştırdı
bizim Kayseride bir laf vardır Atam da
şöyle derler Bu kızda yenilmiyor devamlı
bir yenileme yenileme yenileme yenileme
ile uğraştım hayat boyu ama beni
yenemediler Ata şimdi Şaka yapıyorlar
beni yenemeyeceksiniz diyorum onlara
Evet beni yenemediler peki ya yeni
seydim yarışım Sen sevdin ya beni
Yenilmez yapan etrafındaki tam Yenilmeye
yüz tuttuğum savaşma gücünü kaybettiğim
sırada etrafında toplanıp beni kaldıran
ve her birinden ayrı ayrı bir şey
öğrendim Kadınlar olmasaydı yağışın
sönseydi kadın olmak çok zor zanaat
işinizde erkek gibi olsanız başarılı
olmak için ki hayatının büyük bir
bölümünü böyle geçirdim Bu kadın çok
erkek gibi derler biraz kadınlarınıza
dikkat etseniz kadınsı olsanız çok kadın
kadın derler işinizi önem verseniz
eşiniz kızlar annelerinize önem verseniz
işiniz kızar Beach olmadı Babanız kızar
bu kararlı olsanız agresif kadınlarla
net olsanız çok sert derler anlayışlı
olsanız zayıf yumuşak derler biraz güzel
giyineyim kendime bakayım deseniz çok
süslü
o kadın gibi derler Allah o zaman
mütevazi olayım deseniz Bu sefer de hiç
bu konudaki bir kadına böyle giymek
yakışıyor derler ne deseniz Yar
alamadığımız bir dünyada yaşıyoruz
yaşamayı öğrenmek zorundayız en kötüsü
ne biliyor musunuz Bir gün aynaya bakıp
karşı karşıya geldiğinizde de neden bu
kadar Ne derler diye umursadığım neden
kendi istediklerimi yapmadım Neden
hayatı kaçırdım diye pişman olmak ben
bunları düşünürken magazin dergisinden
bir teklif geldi Geçen yaz Dediler ki
biz de kapak olurmusunuz ne kapağı
Nereden çıktı bu ne düşüneceğimi bile
bilemedim iltifat mı hakaret mi kafamda
biliyorsunuz Biz Kadınlar çok şey
döndürürüz hangisi son 2'den bu konuyu
bir düşüneyim ki magazin dergisine kapak
olur
iyi geceler de böyle 8 tane lüks Arabayı
yan yana düzen içinde Rus bir sürü
kadını bir araya toplayan her gün
hayatının yeni bir aşkını basın açılsın
tanıştıran insanlar magazin dergilerine
kapak olur ne ya dedim bu adamlar kapak
oluyor bu adamlar kapak olduğu için
Türkiye bu halde o zaman neden benim
gibi neredeyse 50 yaşına varmış 30
yıldır evli 3 çocuklu sıradan Kayseri
bir kadın aleme kapak olmasın olsun Ben
de bu da bu duyguları da kapak olsun
diye bu teklifi kabul ettim aklınızda
bulunsun bir şeyi düşünüp de cesaret
edemediğiniz de ya bu bana yakışır mı
acaba yapabilir miyim düşün diye
düşündüğünüz de en kötü ne olur diye
düşün sen öyle düşün en kötü ne olur en
kötü kızlarımın ileride çocuklarına
gösterici ya bakın
ben size hiç fena kadın değildi diye
bilecekleri profesyonel çekilmiş
fotoğraflarım olur diye düşündüm Evet
sonra hayatıma arıyorlar girdi önce Game
of Thrones daki araya girdi Ben diziyi
seyretmeye başladım zaman araya daha o
zaman dünyayı kurtaracağım bile
bilmiyorum araya hayran kaldım Onun o
küçük haliyle bütün zorluklara karşı
gelmesi karşı koyması ama inanılmaz
ilham verdi dedim ki yalnız bu dünyada
Şu aralar gibi çok kadın olsa nasıl bir
yer olurdu Bu dünya harika olur dedim O
zaman iki tane kocaman kızım vardı Bir
daha da çocuk yapmayı düşünüyordum ama
içimden şunu geçirdim bir daha bir kızım
daha olursa adını mutlaka Arya koyacağım
ve Arya Umarım buradaki araya gibi
dünyaya ders veren bir çocuk olabiliriz
Allah bana başka bir araya verdi Arya
şimdi 7 yaşında Tabii ki
ve hiç düşünmedim bu çocuğun ismini ne
koyacağım diye bunu işaret olduğunu
düşündüm ismini araya koydum aryalar
benim kadınlık lı olan tüm şey mi kırk
yaşından sonra İnanılmaz bir şekilde
değiştirdi ortada gördüğünüz İngilizce
olan mektup altı yaşında benim arayamam
bana yazdığı bir mektup rahatını şöyle
diyor Biz dünyadaki en zeki insanlarız
Biz olmadan Siz ne yapardınız size
bilmeniz gereken her şeyi Biz
anlatacağız bütün sorulara cevabınız var
Ve siz dinleyeceksin şaşırdım kaldım
Nasıl oluyor da sonra düşün Bütün
Kadınlar böyle doğru aslında bizler her
şeyin cevabını bildiğiniz düşünerek
müthiş bir ışıkla doğuyoruz Okulda en
başarılı Biz üniversiteye çok giren
biziz önde koşuyoruz her yerde en güzel
konuşan bizi sorun bize de birdenbire
ışığımız sönüyor hayatın içinde kaybolup
gidiyoruz
sen ayarla beraber kadınları keşfettim
hayatta nasıl Yenilmez olacağını
kadınlarla sağladım ip ışık nasıl söner
o bazen canınızı alırlar birden bire
söner Ama bazen de benim annem de olduğu
gibi bi önce iş ışığınızı yavaş yavaş
döndürürler kendinize güveninizi alırlar
sütü Karlar annelik vicdanınızı
kullanırlar ışığınızı yavaş yavaş
söndürüldümü ondan sonra Bir bakarsınız
hayatın içinde işte kendinizi Böyle koca
koca adamların olduğu yerlerde
Fotoğraflar arasında çıkmaya çalışırken
bulursunuz hayatınızı saçmalıklarla
harcamış olursunuz ışığınız yavaş yavaş
döner Ben genellikle bir resimde ne
yanlış diye bakacağım ama hep bu resimde
ne doğru
bu ederim insanlara bu resimde gitsek
doğru şey şuradan aradan kendini
çıkarmaya çalışan kadın Ben değişim
işini transformasyon içindeyim
beğenmediğim şeyi değiştirmeyi severim
değişmesini beklemeye sabrım yok Size
iyi haberler vermek isterdim kadın ve
erkeğin arasındaki İşte bu eşitlik
yakında Kapanacak falan verdi mi haber
diye soracak olursanız Amerika'da 200
içinde kadınla erkek arasındaki cinsiyet
farklı kapanacakmış YouTube haber ne
benimle sizin ne de bizim çocuklarımızın
buna baktı yok Dolayısıyla Bu resmini
değiştirmesini birilerinin gelip de bu
güneşin değiştirmesini beklemektense
kendi resmimizi yapmak zorundayız ben de
öyle yaptım Arya bunu kurdu mayonu ne
yapıyor ayrımın benim gibi hayatta bir
yerlere gelmiş iyi şeyler yapmış
başarılı olmuş insanların ışığını
bu yansıtmasını sağlayacak bir yatırım
platform bizim gibi kadınlar başka
kadınları yatırım yapsın Kızının
geleceği ile ilgili endişeli dünyayı
kadınlarla daha iyi bir yer olarak gören
erkeklerin yatırım yaptığı kadını bir
fırsat olarak gören insanların gelip
kadınlara yatırım yaptığı kadın
girişimcileri yatırım yaptı bir laf
kadınların ışığın parlamasını sağlıyoruz
birbirimize Işık yansıtmayı sağlıyoruz
yine kadar iki buçuk milyon dolardan
fazla kadın girişimciliğine ki
şirketlere yatırım topladık Birleşmiş
Milletler'in öncelikli Kalkınma
hedeflerine bakarsınız bir tanesi
cinsiyet eşitliğini kapanması neden bu
kadar önemli çünkü bu ne kadar kapanışta
dünya için daha İyiler dünya kadınlarla
daha iyi olacağını herkes görüyor artık
kadının olduğu yerler hem şirketleri hem
toplumları hem dünyayı daha iyi yapıyor
sonuçlar bunu gösteriyor ve matematik
12 neden bunları gördüğümüz halde biz
hala kadının hak ettiği yere koymuyoruz
ulu önderimiz Atatürk Tabii ki yine
herkesten Yıllar yıllar önce bu işin
çözümü bizde söylemiş Bir kütle düşünün
ki demiş bir cisim düşünün İki parçadan
olsun kadın ve erkek parçanın bir
tarafını öyle doğru hareket ettirirken
diğeri arkada Kalsın o cismi ilerlemesi
mümkün değildir fizik kurallarını kadın
ve erkeğin birlikte olmadığı birlikte
gelişmediği hiç bir toplum için ülke
ilerleyemez ilerliyorsa da çok az
Yeniçeri stil olacaktır R Evet çok
ilerlemeler var pek çok hak kazandık
yeterli mi Hayır değil Bunu değiştirmek
için başkalarının bize iyilik yapmasını
mı bekleyeceğiz Hayır beklemeyeceğiz
kimseye arkamızdan içmeyecek Hanımlar
bunu anlayalım
ki biz birbirimizi yukarı çekmek
zorundayız herkes gücü yettiğince birini
çekecek yukarı çıkan da Diğerlerinin
yanına çekecek şuna inanınki belli bir
seviyeye geldikten sonra ve kadının
kalktığı katma değeri gerçekten insanlar
gördükten sonra trene binen başkaları
olacak ve bunlar sadece kadınlar
olmayacak erkeklerde otur alabilecekler
ona her zaman sorar Lara Hanım en iyi
yatırım fırsatı nedir diye benim için
yeni yatırım fırsatı yeni altın kadındır
kadın dünyada inanılmaz şekilde
kullanılmayan Atıl kalmış müthiş bir
kaynak biliyorum çünkü yıllarca keşf
edilmeyi bekledim her toplantıda
birileri beni dinlesin diye uğraştım
herkesten çok çalıştım herkesten çok
hazırlandım ama kimse beni keşfetmedi
pek galiba avantajım çok iyi kadınlarla
çevrili olmam ve pes etmem
mı başka kadınlara zaman kazandırmak
istiyorum ve ışıkları parlatmak
istiyorum Bunlar da çok uğraştı mı gören
Arkadaşlarım bazen şey diyor ya al
Bunlarla uğraşıyoruz dünyayı
kurtaracağız Evet dünyayı kurtaracağım
dünyayı ben kurtaracağım beraber
kurtaracağız hem de hazırlıklı geldi Bi
şimdi sizden ayağa kalkmamız rica
edeceğim Lütfen telefonlarının ışığını
Açın açın Işık larınızı yakın ışıklarını
zıbı yanınızdaki arkadaşınızla tutun
birbirinize aydınlatın
bu onun ışığı sönmeye başladığı zaman
siz onu ışığınız aydınlatın sizin
ışığını sanmaya başladı zaman o size
aydınlatsın hep birlikte dünyayı
aydınlatalım dünyayı Bizler kurtaracağız
ama tekli farkla Biz bunu erkeklerle
birlikte yapacağız Çünkü atamızın sözünü
dinliyoruz erkeklerin yaptığı gibi
bizler dünyayı kurtarırken erkekleri
geride bırakmayacağız onları da yanımıza
alacağız hep birlikte dünyayı daha iyi
bir yer yapacağız tek şartımız Lütfen
kimsenin ışığını söndürmesin izin
vermedim